hw 103 spaniens bietet zu gehen wir sind
so schnell wie ein formel 1 wagen
mit bis zu 350 kilometern pro stunde
rast er über die schnellfahrstrecke des
landes
doch das tempo birgt auch gefahren
besonders bei schlechtem wetter
wirbelt schnee auf
heute mit einem der schnellsten züge der
welt
der hochgeschwindigkeitszug a b 103 hat
den spanischen schienenverkehr
revolutioniert
die wichtigste und meistgenutzte
zugverbindung ist die zwischen madrid
und barcelona
morgen fahren die züge im 15 minuten
takt danach etwa einmal die stunde
ihren offen alle linien zusammen im
bahnhof atocha in der hauptstadt madrid
den bahnhof atocha gibt es seit mitte
des neunzehnten jahrhunderts 20
millionen menschen nutzen in der ein
schnellzug wie der aber 103 braucht
besondere schienen und bahnsteigen und
speziell ausgebildete fahrer ich heim
ich bin schon ganz aufgeregt
dieser zug ist so schnell es muss
unglaublich sein ihn zu fahren
in einem schnellzug ist es auf jeden
fall spannender als in einem normalen es
macht viel spaß
die strecke madrid barcelona ist 621
kilometer lang
nach einem zwischenstopp im nordöstlich
gelegenen saragossa geht es weiter in
die autonome region katalonien
vor bayern den städten jena und
montblanc und die küste entlang richtung
barcelona
[Musik]
das alles in gerade mal zweieinhalb
stunden
in einer gewöhnlichen eisenbahn dauert
die fahrt bis zu dreimal so lang
doch heute wird sie wohl auch der aw
verspäten auf einem teil der strecke hat
es geschneit
arroyo kam nicht wie gewohnt vollgas
geben
statt 300 kilometern pro stunde schaffen
wir dort wahrscheinlich nur 160
der staatliche eisenbahn konzern rente
muss ich bei jedem wetter auch seine
züge verlassen können darum werden alle
drehgestelle regelmäßig gewartet nach
einer gewissen kilometer zahlen müssen
die räder ausgewechselt werden
selbst kleinste unebenheiten können zu
schweren unfällen führen warum werden
die räder mit der drehmaschine glatt
geschliffen
wenn wir den zug nicht regelmäßig warten
würden könnten schlimme unfälle
passieren
[Musik]
doch nichts hält ewig selbst bei guter
pflege
diese räder sind zu abgenutzt um sie
wieder instand zu setzen
darum bauen wir jetzt die achslager aus
und tauschen die alten radsätze gegen
neue
die mechaniker wissen je schneller der
zug desto eher schwächelt das material
während die servicecrew putzt und die
vorräte auf füllt die triebwagenführer
arroyo seine checkliste durch
laut vorschrift müssen wir als erstes
die bremsen testen
es ist fast wie in einem flugzeugcockpit
wenn es ein problem gibt können wir
natürlich nicht losfahren
der aw 103 ist knapp vier meter hoch
drei meter breit und 200 meter lang
seine acht waggons bestehen aus leichtem
aluminium
[Musik]
er hat an beiden enden führerstände und
bietet platz für 405 passagieren der
speisewagen trennt die erste von der
zweiten klasse
[Musik]
aber es steht für alter velociped
espanola also spanische
hochgeschwindigkeit und bedeutet
gleichzeitig vogel
sobald der zug startklar ist können die
passagiere einsteigen wir versuchen das
alles so schnell wie möglich abläuft
[Musik]
die abfertigung kostet allerdings ein
wenig zeit
roger ist ein schöner bart allerdings
gibt es hier seit den terroranschlägen
im jahr 2004 strenge
sicherheitskontrollen
am 11 märz 2004 explodierten zehn bomben
vier vollbesetzten pendlerzügen
terroristen hatten sie an bord
geschmuggelt und bei der einfahrt in den
bahnhof atocha
191 menschen kann und sehen mehr als
1800 wurden verletzt
sicherheitsteam unter antonio bertone
ist dafür verantwortlich dass so eine
tragödie nie wieder passiert
wir haben neue waffen der lektoren und
alarmanlagen installiert außerdem sind
die kameras und scanner viel
leistungsfähiger als früher
jedes gepäckstück wird durchleuchtet
jeder passagier abgetastet und das ist
noch nicht alles
wir sind hier in der
überwachungszentrale
374 kameras zeichnen rund um die uhr
alles auf was in und um den bahnhof
herum passiert wenn nötig kann man ganz
nah ran suchen
auf b1 alles klar in der bahnhofshalle
seelen bundespolizisten nach dem rechten
kinder kontrollieren wir mal
okay
guten tag können wir ihre papiere sehen
gibt es ein problem
sie halten ausschau nach verdächtigen
personen
es gibt bestimmte verhaltensweisen die
darauf hindeuten können dass etwas nicht
stimmt wenn eine person nervös hin und
her geht oder sich immer wieder um
schaut so etwas bemerken wir sofort
unterstützung bekommen die polizisten
von 52 spüren
unsere hunde sind auf drogen und
sprengstoff versteckte personen gleichen
teile geld und brandbeschleuniger
abgerichtet
alles zum schutz der passagiere
der 103 startet über 20 mal am tag
rechnung barcelona der zeitplan ist eng
wer nicht mindestens
gleich gehts los während die letzten
passagiere einsteigen bereiten die
zugbegleiter alles für die fahrt fuhr
wir haben den bahnhof pünktlich um halb
neun verlassen und fahren jetzt nach
saragossa unserem ersten und einzigen
zwischenhalt auf
dem weg durch wert der habe die
messetore das kastilischen hochland
würde oben ist es bedeutend kühlern
manchmal schneider sogar
im norden willkommen an bord des ave
nach barcelona
außerhalb der hauptstadt nimmt der
zugfahrt auf der aare kann bis zu 350
kilometer pro stunde fahren das liegt
allerdings nicht an der lok dieser zug
hat nämlich gar keine klassische lockt
der a b 103 ist wie sein vorbild der
ice3 ein sogenannter triebzug seine 16
elektrischen unterflur motoren verteilen
sich auf vier triebwagen und bringen
zusammen eine leistung von 8800 kilowatt
mit so viel power kann der aber mehr
passagiere in kürzerer zeit ans ziel
bringen als an herkömmlichen zu
[Musik]
nach zwölf jahren bauzeit wurde die
schnellfahrstrecke zwischen madrid und
barcelona 2008 eröffnet das acht
milliarden euro teure projekt war für
die eisenbahn ingenieure eine große
herausforderung
die verbindung hat 45 tunnel mit einer
gesamtlänge von 50 kilometern der
längste tunnel ist fast fünf kilometer
lang dazu kamen noch 50 viadukte mit
einer gesamtlänge von 32 kilometern das
zu planen war eine menge arbeit
damit der aber eine echte alternative zu
anderen verkehrsmitteln werden konnte
mussten die ingenieure die strecke so
gerade wie möglich anlegen
[Musik]
zwischen madrid und barcelona gibt es
gute flugverbindungen und eine autobahn
harte konkurrenz
der plan ist aufgegangen
der aber ist bei pendlern und urlaubern
gleichermaßen beliebte
[Musik]
je mehr leute zug fahren desto weniger
steigen in den flieger
im jahr 2017 haben mehr als 60 prozent
der reisenden zwischen madrid und
barcelona in schnellzug gewählt das
einzige was den fahrgästen ab und an die
stimmung verhagelt ist das wetter
spanien liegt zwar im süden auf der
hochebene kann es aber ziemlich kalt
wissen so viel schnee wie heute ist
allerdings auch hier für einen
schnellzug sind diese bedingungen alles
andere als ich mir scheint als hätten
wir ein problem
für zug wirbelt jede menge schnee auf
bei diesem wetter sind 300 kilometer pro
stunde keine konkrete
es ist schlimmer als vorhergesagt
der fahrer sieht nur was vor ihm ist
darum berichten wir regelmäßig was am
anderen ende des zuges passiert
aber nicht die schnee verbindung sind
das problem sondern der schnee und das
eis auf dem gleis
es kann die räder blockieren und dem zug
aus dem gleichgewicht bringen
[Applaus]
darum fährt der aber jetzt ein wenig
langsamer
pro tag befördern wir auf dieser strecke
etwa 27.000 passagiere bei einer
reisegeschwindigkeit von 300 kilometern
pro stunde
die züge sind sehr zuverlässig
heute müssen die fahrgäste jedoch eine
verspätung in kauf nehmen vollgas ist
bei diesem wetter nicht trennt
zugführer spricht gerade mit dem fahrer
offenbar hat sich an den seiten eis
gelöst und ist unter die räder geraten
sie beraten wie es weitergeht
wir wirbeln so viel schnee auf dass man
hinten kaum noch was sieht
ich kann nicht mal mehr die gleise
erkennen
doch genau dort auf den gleisen die die
gefahr
wenn wir mit hoher geschwindigkeit über
eine eisschicht fahren können stücke
davon in die motoren gelangen und
schaden anrichten
damit ist nicht zu spaßen
personal will die passagiere nicht
unnötig beunruhigen doch es gibt allen
grund vorsichtig zu sein der
aufgewirbelte schnee kann am warmen
unterboden und an den seiten des zugs
halten werden
verlangt er von dort in die drehgestelle
sachsen blockieren die bodenhaftung
verlieren und die bremsen
beeinträchtigen dann droht im
schlimmsten fall eine entgleisung
frost bedingte unfälle sind in
nördlichen gefilden keine seltenheit im
november 2015 entlasten in kanada ein
güterzug weil er über ein von eis
beschädigtes gleis gefahren war 15
waggons krachten in ein flussbett zum
glück wurde niemand schwer verletzt
heyme arroyo wird langsam nervös
wir können über funk kontakt zur
leitstelle aufnehmen gott haben sie alle
strecken im blick
ruft im kontrollzentrum in saragossa
wir müssen sie darüber informieren was
hier los ist
auf dieser strecke fahren täglich
dutzende züge oft nur wenige fahrminuten
von einander entfernt die leute in der
leitstelle sorgen dafür dass niemand zu
schaden kommt und alles reibungslos
läuft
kontrollzentrum saragossa
ein mitarbeiter gibt das aktuelle
tempolimit durch
[Musik]
30 83
bitte beachten wegen des schnees dürfen
sie derzeit nicht schneller fahren als
160 kilometer vor stunde
ist das recht durch schnee zu fahren
erfordert höchste konzentration
der zug verhält sich anders er rutscht
der avl wird saragossa definitiv zu spät
erreicht genau wie alle anderen züge die
durch das schneegebiet müssen
wenn der zug über die verschneiten
gleise fährt kann der schnee zu eis der
club das müssen wir vermeiden sind die
angestellten in der leitstelle haben
alle hände voll zu tun diese beiden züge
fahren gleich schnell in dieselbe
richtung
auf ihren bildschirmen verfolgen sie
jeden zug der zwischen madrid und der
französischen grenze unterwegs ist
[Musik]
ist meine mitarbeiter überwachen alle
signalanlagen knotenpunkte und weichen
auf dieser strecke
so stellen sie sicher dass die züge
immer pünktlich und unbeschadet ans ziel
kommen
ist sich seiner verantwortung bewusst
als lokführer hatte ich einen wichtigen
job ich muss dafür sorgen dass der zug
sicher fährt und dass alle systeme
funktionieren die gesamte technik liegt
komplett in meiner hat
nach 100 langsamen kilometern lässt er
aber das schneegebiet endlich hinter
sich
jetzt kann er rojo gas geben allerdings
nur kurz wenn er in 20 minuten saragossa
erreicht muss er die geschwindigkeit
schon wieder draußen
[Musik]
auch was die bremsen angeht
unterscheidet sich der aw 103 von
herkömmlichen schulen er bremst nämlich
in erster linie elektrisch
während der fahrt trat strom aus der
oberleitung die fahrmotoren an wird die
stromzufuhr gekappt entsteht in den
motoren ein widerstand der d-zug
verlangsamt
[Musik]
die dabei gewonnene bremsenergie wird
entweder als wärme abgegeben oder zurück
ins stromnetz gespeist
und das ist gut für die umwelt
[Musik]
für die meisten passagiere zählt jedoch
vor allem der komfort
alberto fahren sie beruflich nach
barcelona
er heute schon
meistens war ich aber privat meine
familie und freunde leben
kommt aus barcelona arbeitet aber in
materie
warum nehmen sie dazu
weil er komfortabel und pünktlich ist
für mich ist das die beste und
einfachste option
damit das auch so bleibt wird das
schienennetz
regelmäßig gewartet
wegen des dichten verkehrs geht das
allerdings nur nachts
[Musik]
heute soll ein teil des gleisbettes
instand gesetzt werden
kontrollierte den zustand und die
position der hydraulik systeme
die maschine simuliert ein gewicht von
50 tonnen zwischen den achsen so wird
der schotter gleichmäßig verteilt
der sogenannte dynamische gleis
stabilisator versetzt den schotter in
schwingung und bewirkt dass sich die
gleise schön gleichmäßig eingraben
so entsteht eine gerade und stabile
fahrbahn
[Musik]
die reste crew überprüft unterdessen die
stromversorgung
manchmal kommt es vor dass die
oberleitung reist zum beispiel durch
eine spannung spitze oder vogelschlag
oder weil eine aufhängung beschädigt ist
das ist sehr kompliziert zu reparieren
meistens müssen wir den zugverkehr dann
einen ganzen tag stilllegen
auch das wetter spielt eine rolle je
nach temperatur denen sich die leitungen
aus oder ziehen sich zusammen dabei kann
immer etwas kaputtgehen
meine mitarbeiter schrauben jetzt das
gerüst auf in den mast die befestigungen
und die isolatoren zu kontrollieren
falls sich dort etwas gelockert hat
könnte ein unfall passieren das wollen
wir verhindern
wo schicht prüft die crew etwa drei
kilometer strecke
an bord des ave blickt viktorianer
martin besorgt auf die uhr
im schnee gebiet mussten wir langsam
erfahren darum haben wir jetzt 20
minuten verspätet
die crew möchte die verspätung gerne
aufholen doch sie sollte nicht zu sehr
auf die tube drücken das gilt vor allem
in den kurven
sonst droht eine ähnliche katastrophe
wie hier
noch 5 km für saragossa
während die fahrgäste aus wohnen oder
arbeiten bereitet sich zugchef
vittoriano martin mental auf die
zwischen stopfen er möchte ungern noch
mehr zeit verlieren
sobald alle passagiere eingestiegen und
die türen geschlossen sind fahren wir
weiter
spaniens
hochgeschwindigkeitszüge gelten als sehr
zuverlässig und sicher
doch überall wo menschen arbeiten kann
es zu fehlern kommen und auch das beste
sicherheitssystem als schwachstelle
vor ein paar jahren es gab es im norden
spaniens einen schlimmen unfall mit
dutzenden toten
das unglück passierte am 24 juni 2013 in
der nähe der pilgerstadt santiago de
compostela
ein schnellzug von calvia womit 190
kilometern pro stunde auf eine enge
kurve zu machen abgelenkt von einem
handy telefonat vergaß der lokführer
rechtzeitig zu bremsen
der zug entgleiste und krachte er in
eine betonmauer 80 menschen ums leben
144 wurden verletzt
der fahrer hat einen fehler gemacht aber
viele meinen der unfall hätte trotzdem
verhindert werden können
nach dem unglück hat sich in punkto
sicherheit einiges getan
in der leitstelle in saragossa arbeiten
die fahrdienstleiter mit dem european
rail traffic management system
tms
das system bremszüge die das tempo limit
überschreiten automatisch ab
tms wird europaweit eingesetzt
das erleichtert die zusammenarbeit enorm
sensoren im gleisbett registrieren die
position geschwindigkeit und die
richtung jedes zubiss
über diese leitungen hinter mir
empfangen wir alle daten die die
sensoren aufnehmen
so wird sichergestellt dass die züge
einen bestimmten mindestabstand nie
unterschreiten
dadurch können mehr züge gleichzeitig
auf derselben strecke fahren
passiert ein zug einen iaa tms sensor
überträgt diese ein signal an eine unter
dem zug installierte antennen
aus den daten errechnet das system die
geschwindigkeit ist sie zu hoch fordert
es den lokführer auf zu bremsen
wenn er nicht reagiert leite es eine
zwangsbremsung 1
das neue system ist so sicher dass wir
den mindestabstand zwischen zwei zügen
auf drei minuten verringern könnten
anderen zug leitsystemen beträgt der
sechs acht zehn oder sogar 12
nach gut 300 kilometern fährt der aber
103 in den bahnhof von saragossa 1
halbzeit
vom bahnsteig aus überwacht vittoriano
martin das ein und aussteigen der
passagiere
erst als alle an bord sind streckt auch
hier wieder ein
innerhalb weniger minuten geht es weiter
hayo hat freie bahn und beschleunigt auf
300 km pro stunde
spaniens schnellbahnnetz ist nach chinas
das zweitgrößte der welt und das wird
permanent erweitert
der ausbau der schnellfahrstrecke ist
eines der größten infrastrukturprojekte
in der geschichte spaniens
das liegt unter anderem an den vielen
bergen die kosten für all die brücken
und tunnel gehen in die milliarden
einer der geplanten neuen
streckenabschnitte führt von st ins
weiter nördlich gelegene grenze
zwischen den beiden städten liegt das
kleine dorf die kirche
[Musik]
hier gestaltet sich die arbeit besonders
schwer
die berge sind zu stein um gleise
darüber zu legen und zubereitung sie
drum herum zu legen
[Musik]
die einzige lösung ein tunnel mitten
hindurch
doch es gibt ein problem
genau über dem geplanten tunneleingang
verläuft eine andere bahn strecke die
crew um bauleiter juan pablo bmw war
musste sich etwas einfallen lassen
wir haben einen weg gefunden das problem
zu umgehen
diese maschine drückt sich unter der
bahnstrecke hindurch in den berg so kann
der verkehr darüber normal weiterlaufen
als erstes graben die männer eine höhle
in den berg
danach 715 starke hydraulikzylinder eine
4000 tonnen schwere betonröhre stück für
stück in den berg
so entsteht unter den bahnschienen 100
meter langer tunnel
doch die arbeit ist langwierig
[Musik]
das ganze dauert etwa eineinhalb monate
auf der anderen seite sind zum glück
keine schienen im weg wir können die
tunnelarbeiter den weg einfach frei
sprengen
wir verbinden den sprengstoff
und lassen dann die turniere
der tunnel reichstes hinter die kurve da
hinten und in wenigen minuten kommt
wieder ein kleines stück dazu die
arbeiter haben an den wänden sprengsätze
angebracht und werden sie gleich zünden
also besser schnell raus hier
pro sprengung geht es etwa einen meter
voran als erstes jagen die arbeiter 250
kilo platine den er mit in die luft
es entstanden girl transportieren sie
anschließend mit baggerlader ins freie
[Musik]
der tunnel liegt 300 meter tief unter
schiefer und granitgestein
unter dem enormen gewicht gibt die
tunneldecke jeden tag ein paar
zentimeter nach
damit sie nicht einstürzt stützen die
arbeiter sie mit einem stahlgerüst ab
und kleiden sie anschließend mit beton
aus
[Musik]
dieser berg kraft es uns ganz schön
schwer an einigen stellen ist die
tunneldecke bis zu 30cm abgesagt
[Musik]
sobald der beton aufgetragen ist die das
weiter
das ganze wiederholen wir ungefähr
dreimal am tag am abend sind dann vier
bis fünf meter vorangekommen
wenn die arbeiter fertig sind führt
einer zweieinhalb kilometer langer
schnellfahrstrecke gerade durch den berg
europas größtes highspeed netz wächst
immer weiter in naher zukunft soll jeder
einwohner spaniens höchstens 50
kilometer von einer
hochgeschwindigkeitsstrecke entfernt
wohnen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
auch in barcelona wird fleißig gebaut
die katalanische metropole hat bereits
einen großen bahnhof mit highspeed
anbindung
nun soll im norden der stadt ein zweiter
dazu kommen
barcelonas erklären
der bahnhof la sagrada wird das größte
gebäude der stadt
mit bank lassen auf mehreren ebenen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bis zu 100 millionen reisende sollen im
bahnhof jährlich nutzen
[Musik]
ingenieur giulia kann das ende der
bauarbeiten kaum erwarten
der neue bahnhof hat acht gleise für
schnellzüge und acht für regionalzüge
dadurch ist das system stabiler und
verlässlicher
seit 1992 die ersten gleise verlegt
wurden haben die schnellfahrstrecke
spaniens eisenbahnverkehr auf trab
gebracht
als ich noch zur schule gingst meinten
alle das bahnnetz er sei so schlecht
weil das land so bergig ist aber das
stimmt nicht klar bleiben die berge die
kosten in die höhe aber ein noch viel
größerer kostenfaktor sind die dicht
bebauten städten
doch trotz aller schwierigkeiten haben
die ingenieure es geschafft die strecke
relativ gerade zu bauen so können die
lokführer alles aus dem a b 103
herausholen es empfinden sie es immer
noch aufregend mit diesen zug zu fahren
auf jeden fall
stellen sie sich vor wir sind ungefähr
so schnell wie ein formel 1 was wir
brauchen aber keine sicherheitsgurte
wir können jederzeit aufstehen ein
bisschen spazieren gehen wurde ein
bistro einen kaffee trinken
auch für den lokführer ist jeder
arbeitstag ein erlebnis
wenn das display 300 kilometer pro
stunde zeigt ist man zuerst etwas
angespannt aber
mit der zeit gewöhnt man sich dran und
ist einfach nur noch die geister
wie die meisten schnellzüge wird auch
der a b 103 elektrisch angetrieben der
strom dafür kommt aus sogenannten unter
werken entlang der strecke wir prüfen ob
die leitungen noch unter spannung stehen
wenn du hier einen schlag kriegst ist er
sofort tot
heute steht eine wartung der anstoß
stücke an dafür muss die crew den strom
vorübergehend abschalten
durch diese 400 tausend volt leitungen
jetzt der strom in die transformatoren
vom unter wer
einmal im jahr müssen wir alle
verbindungen prüfen und sicherstellen
dass sie richtig sitzt
ansonsten könnten überhitzen und feiert
ein großes problem
zwischen madrid und barcelona haben wir
15 unterberg
jedes von ihnen versorgt zwischen 50 und
60 km strecke mit strom
die 400.000 volt spannung aus dem
hochspannungsnetz werden in den
transformatoren der unter werke in 25
tausend volt umgewandelt und in die
oberleitungen der eisenbahnstrecke
gespeist und dort fließt der strom über
stromabnehmer in den zug wird ein
weiteres mal umgewandelt und reif
schließlich die fahrmotoren an
[Musik]
die strecke ist so angelegt dass die
stromversorgung auch dann noch
sichergestellt ist wenn eins der unter
werke aus fährt
wir müssen die züge wieder langsamer
noch selten erfahren
[Musik]
würde der ave 103 von einer gewöhnlichen
diesellokomotive angetrieben wäre er
viel schwerer und langsamer der
elektrische unterflur antrieb ist eine
effiziente alternative
[Musik]
seit mehr als 25 jahren gehören spaniens
hochgeschwindigkeitszüge zu den
schnellsten der welt und das soll noch
lange so bleiben
wir arbeiten ununterbrochen daran
leistungsfähigere motoren zu entwickeln
und unsere züge noch aero dynamischer
und energiesparender zu gestalten
nächste zug generation ist schon in
planung
sie soll aus dem eigenen land kommen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
unglaublich dass wir gerade 300 sachen
drauf haben die fahrt füllt sich so
ruhig
der aber hat die städte länder und
moslem passiert und nähert sich jetzt
barcelona
während der fahrt muss lokführer kairo
immer wieder einen
sicherheitsmechanismus betätigt
das ist das sogenannte topmann pedal
damit signalisiere ich dass alles okay
ist
muss das pedal regelmäßig und unter
druck wenn ich meinen fuß längere zeit
nicht anheben kommt ein warnton
dann muss ich das pedal kurz loslassen
und wieder antippen tue ich das nicht
bringt das sicherheitssystem den zug
automatisch zum stehen
der mechanismus gehört zur
standardausstattung aller haben züge
eisenbahnen gibt es in spanien schon
seit rund 150 jahren aber ein
spitzenreiter in sachen
hochgeschwindigkeit ist das land erst
seit 1992
wir haben aus verschiedenen ländern wie
etwa deutschland die besten züge und die
besten technologien importiert alle
menton das würde nicht funktionieren
seitdem hat der schienenverkehr auf der
iberischen halbinsel eine beeindruckende
entwicklung durchgemacht bis dahin waren
spanische züge langsam und unzuverlässig
die spuren hatten unterschiedliche
breiten und waren mit denen anderer
länder in europa nicht kompatibel
doch das ist mittlerweile geschichte
langfristig will die regierung das land
so gut vernetzen das von madrid aus
jeder ort in unter vier stunden zu
erreichen ist
[Applaus]
spaniens hochgeschwindigkeitsflotte kann
sich sehen lassen und sie bekommt
zuwachs von diesem brandneuen hightech
zügen
der eisenbahnkonzern rente hat den
spanischen hersteller patentes talk mit
dem bau und der wartung von 15 april
schnellzügen beauftragt kostenpunkt
knapp 800 millionen euro
der april gehört zu den modernsten zügen
der welt das liegt unter anderem daran
dass er voll automatisiert ist
anders als der a b 103 kann der april
theoretisch komplett ferngesteuert
fahren außerdem besteht er aus noch
leichterem material
für mich ist das viel mehr als ein
klassischer zug
der april ist einer der leichtesten
schnellzüge geburt zu einer
reisegeschwindigkeit liegt bei 330 die
höchstgeschwindigkeit bei 365 kilometer
pro stunde dabei verbraucht er weniger
energie als herkömmliche
hochgeschwindigkeits zu
wir setzen hier auf niedrigen
energieverbrauch und nachhaltigkeit
[Musik]
kago exportiert seine
hochgeschwindigkeitszüge sogar nach
saudi arabien
der neue ring bietet platz für bis zu 5
121 passagiere in seiner spezial achsen
passen sich automatisch verschiedenen
spurbreiten an
[Musik]
das ist ein großer vorteil denn dadurch
ist der april viel flexibler und
effizienter als andere schnellzüge
er kann jede beliebige stadt anfangen
egal ob sie an schnellfahren netz
angeschlossen ist oder nicht
in sachen highspeed technologie spielt
spanien ganz vorne mit doch jedes
verkehrsmittel ist nur so gut wie seine
infrastruktur und die muss so einiges
aushalten
naturkatastrophen können überall zur
gefahr werden an der spanischen küste
kommt es oft zu überschwemmungen
kein land ist vor der naturgewalten
sicher auch spanien nicht
stürmer hochwasser und erdbeben können
zur bedrohung werden die waren
ingenieure haben das mit bedacht und die
strecken dementsprechend geplant damit
sich kein wasser in ihnen sammelt sind
viele tunnel beispielsweise leicht
geneigt
[Musik]
bei solchen geschwindigkeiten muss alles
stimmen
hohes tempo braucht eine gute
infrastruktur
ein großer druck für alle beteiligten
ich glaube viele meiner kollegen ganz
schön geschwitzt
sie mussten in kurzer zeit top
ergebnisse liefern
doch am ende hat sich die harte arbeit
ausgezahlt
[Musik]
es ist eine sehr angenehme form des
reisens zwischendurch kann man sich die
beine vertreten oder ein bisschen im
speisewagen rumhängen es geht im
flugzeug oder im auto nicht
kann man die spanische landschaft nicht
genießen
das schönste an meinem job ist der
umgang mit den passagieren wenn sie
glücklich sind bin ich auch glücklich
der hc100 drei nähert sich barcelona
auch den letzten 20 kilometern muss noch
führe aber wegen der vielen kurven erste
mal auf die bremse treten
und während die crew alles für die
ankunft vorbereitet geht es hinein in
den langen tunnel der direkt in den
bahnhof barcelona suns führen
diese letzten kilometer waren für die
konstrukteure eine besondere
herausforderung
die hochgeschwindigkeitsstrecke gebaut
wurde musste der pendler und
regionalverkehr planen wir sich weiter
laufen wir sprechen hier von 1000 zügen
pro tag das war sehr schwierig
barcelona an das
hochgeschwindigkeitsnetz
anzuschließen war eine logistische und
ingenieurtechnische meisterleistung und
der aufwand hat sich gelohnt
mit diesen muss man mindestens einmal
gefahren sein
nach der ankunft können die fahrgäste
entweder die stadt erkunden ein
regionalzug ins umland nehmen oder mit
einem anderen schnellzug nach frankreich
weiter fahren
trotz wetterbedingter verspätung hat die
fahrt keine drei stunden gedauert wir
sind gut durch den schnee durchgegangen
alles hat super geklappt
der haw 103 für den wenigen stunden von
einer metropole in die nächste
ich bin sehr stolz auf diesen zog die
eisenbahnen in denen ich früher
gearbeitet habe haben für die strecke
nach barcelona bis zu sieben stunden
gebraucht wir sind höchstens 140
gefahren und alles hat ewig gedauert
jetzt
steigen wir ein und sind in zweieinhalb
stunden in barcelona
das ist eine tolle sache
der highspeed zug hat den fernverkehr in
spanien auf ein neues level gehoben
das in barcelona es war eine kurze aber
unterhaltsame fahrt ich habe heute viel
über den a b 103 gelernt und ich habe
die leute getroffen die ihn zu dem
gemacht haben was er ist einer der
beeindruckendsten schnellzüge der welt
[Musik]